es gibt wohl kaum eine kultur die mit so
vielen mythen verknüpft ist wie die
mesopotamische kultur die mythenwelt ist
geprägt von den vielen verschiedenen
völkern
vor allem aber die götter geschichten
der sumerer sind von besonderer
bedeutung und sei für die ganze
menschheit sind sie doch quasi die wiege
der menschheit und haben unser wissen
über das zweistromland geprägt denn
schon diese frühe hochkultur hatte eine
schrift wie stellten sich die
mesopotamien die erde vor wie wurden die
menschen ihrer vorstellung nach
erschaffen um was ist heute von diesen
geschichten übriggeblieben klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
ja ein sehr sehr cooler themenvorschlag
von euch aus der web community vielen
dank die sumerer wohnten zwischen den
flüssen tigris und euphrat im heutigen
irak das zweistromland und sie haben
schon damals echt großes geleistet sie
bewässerten ihre felder und betrieben
viehzucht was die grundlage dafür
bildete die ersten städte zu gründen
heute die grundlage unserer zivilisation
ungefähr 3200 jahre vor christi geburt
entwickelten sie die älteste schrift der
menschheit und außerdem beschäftigten
sie sich mit mathematik literatur und
astronomie ihre schrift diente ihnen
dazu umschulden aufzuzählen land zu
vermessen oder wassergräben zu berechnen
aber sie wussten doch noch wenig und
füllten diese lücken mit göttern die
sumerer hatten götter für quasi jede
gelegenheit unterteilt in out und uhr
götter sowie stadt götter die autoren
der mythen spiegelten ihre eigenen
lebensverhältnisse auf die götter und
ließen sie beispielsweise zusammen mit
frau dienern und kindern im jeweiligen
tempelbezirk leben mit den mythen
versuchten die sumerer wohl ihre rituale
institutionen und lebensgewohnheiten zu
erklären und zu legitimieren und sehr
wahrscheinlich ist es auch dass die
sumerer ihre götter geschichten
tatsächlich glaubten ebenso wie ihre
jeweiligen erfinder sie brachten ihnen
opfergaben und baten sie in ritualen und
was hat doch auch hier war es vor allem
die priesterschaft die auch die
politische ordnung maßgeblich bestimmte
die an die geschichten glaubten im
gegensatz zu manch anderen der eher
weltlich oder geistlich unterwegs war
der schöpfungsmythos wie ist alles
entstanden einheitlich sind die
sumerische mythen rund um die schöpfung
nicht zum einen existiert wohl die
vorstellung dass eine kosmische heilige
hochzeit statt gefunden haben sollte
zwischen himmel und erde
dadurch wurde die erde fruchtbar andere
quellen nennen die göttin nano als die
schöpferin von himmel und erde sie soll
beides geboren haben doch warum wurde
der mensch nach den vorstellungen der
sumerer überhaupt geboren die götter
hatten demnach zu viel arbeit und hatten
den wunsch dass dies jemand für sie
übernimmt und sie zudem auch mit
versorgt und so wurden die menschen aus
schlamm erschaffen wir erinnern uns
bibel an anderer stelle wird beschrieben
wie die menschen aus einem erdloch
herauswachsen dass der göttervater n
will nach der trennung von himmel und
erde mit einer hacke erschaffen hatte
das weltbild so stellen sich die
mesopotamien die erde vor erde und
kosmos waren nach vorstellungen der
messe porta eine geteilte hohlkugeln
also eine kugel die in zwei gleiche
hälften geteilt ist oben noch klarer
himmel mit sternen unten die unterwelt
zwischen den beiden halbkugeln ein
gebirge mit dem salzwasser ozean namens
tiamat und in diesem monat insel die
erde und unter ihr ein weiterer ozean
allerdings aus süßwasser ja und im
zentrum der erdstöße podien und alle
anderen länder drumherum bezeichnet wird
das als alt orientalisches weltbild das
später dann durch geografische
entdeckung überholt wurde bis heute
erhalten geblieben einige mythen gingen
in spätere religionen ein ihr kennt sich
ja alle die sünden im paradies stichwort
adam und eva nachzulesen auch in der
bibel eine vorlage dafür war ein mythos
der sumerer der von einem glücklichen
land berichtet in ihm gab es keine
krankheiten oder raubtiere der weisheits
genki verlangte nach wasser das cover
und der sonnengott otto ließ das wasser
aus der erde sprudeln das glückliche
landwirt noch glücklicher mit vielen
pflanzen und sehr fruchtbaren boden acht
besondere pflanzen wachsen hier und
jetzt könnt ihr euch schon fast denken
was passiert obwohl die göttin ninja
sack es verboten hatte ist enkel alle
auf er wird von ihr verflucht und wird
krank die anderen götter setzen sich für
ihn ein und ninja sack erschafft acht
heil götter ihr seht also die mythenwelt
der sumerer ist über jahrtausende
bestehen geblieben auch einige andere
geschichten sind in biblische
überlieferung eingeschossen echt irre
wie greifbar
die mythen der menschheit sind man kann
sie nachlesen und sie sind am ende gar
nicht so geheimnisvoll wenn ihr in
zukunft kein video verpassen wollt dann
endet mich bei whatsapp dann umgeht ihn
die kaputte am boxi auf youtube und ihr
verpasst kein video
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
persönlich
von jedem upload und zwar noch vor allen
anderen täglich garantiert einfach hier
draufklicken und am besten auch mein
schwesterkanal klicks um social media
abonnieren da gibt es das neueste aus
der social media welt dafür hier klicken
aber nicht die genau glocke vergessen
hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken sensationsfund riesiger
sack oft gibt rätsel auf bis dann bleibt
dran